was geht hier ist euer marx und herzlich
willkommen zur neuen folge lucky gitter
und mit franz ich würde sagen wir legen
einfach nur leute es gibt einige updates
von denen ich euch erzählen kann aber
bevor ich mit den updates starte erst
mal eine wichtige info ab sofort gibt es
lucky guetta und immer mittwochs auf
meinem kanal und samstag auf franz kanal
also wenn ihr keine folge verpassen
wollt einfach mal in die beschreibung
gucken franzen abo da lassen ist auch
sonst ein supercooler typen at once
bisher richtig cool zu den updates leute
ihr seht schon ich habe in meinem
inventar unterschiedlichste lucky blöcke
einmal die rainbow lucky blöcke aber die
sperre lucky blöcke und die normalen
lucky blöcke und franz wird gerade von
einer spinne getötet macht nicht ich
habe sie getötet
anhand alter wichtig und richtig als
trage ich hatte hier in krippe und hp
critical hitzegrade angewendet live
pr.com ihr ist aber nicht politik direkt
im krieg darunter gefallen er war so
perplex ich bin wie sehr ich der neiße
kran sind wer nicht den meisten fahren
kennt eine person gehört wieder auch mal
jonathan oder naja ich bin - das kann
hier ist noch ein bisschen wasser ich
werde es auf keinen fall ausnutzen und
wissen verboten oder du wirst es auf
keinen fall ausnutzen heißt dass das
ausland zulassen oder vielleicht gerade
durch gesprungen einmal aber nicht so
extrem aber man darf nicht damit unten
ins wasser reicht sogar aufzuregen
kleinwasserkraft wirklich keinen fall
stammt wie deine jesus und leute ist
mich noch mal gestorben ich war so kurz
vorm ende aber ich finde jeder der es
will sich vergebens holen weil es
einfach nur irgendeine art irgendwie
anders
das finde ich komisch einer nation
frische ninjas kritischen ja eben das
eine sache damit dann fühlen sich
nämlich die leute die sich vielleicht
ein bisschen darüber profilieren dass
sie diese schuhe haben irgendwie in
ihrer
scheinbaren individualität verletzt
sehen genau gleich aus kosten 50 oder
700 sonne
lucky geht an das stöhnen compare achso
kuscheltieren so betrieben hast als du
jünger war s bahn ich hab hier
wie viele blogger hand kein kommentar 27
27 11 von beiden stimmt aber ich weiß
nicht was es ist ja gut ich hab halt ich
hab auch 28 grad ja ja ich glaub sogar
schon 28
ich würde sagen wir fangen an mit dem
auspacken ich bin sehr gespannt was
nehme ich mir erst gar nicht ich hab'
ich habe immer wieder so mein gott ich
habe die apokalypse
alle sterne mein gott junge ist einfach
alles dunkel ich bin ich bin so etwas
passiert was passiert genau das müsst
ihr wissen ja dass auch während der so
lange wir uns nicht einmal geschlagen
solange wir uns sicher einmal geschlagen
haben beginnt die feld solange wir uns
nicht einmal geschlagen haben beginnt
die feier sind noch gar nicht fertig das
ist schon besser ich habe tausende kühe
bekommen nicht ich habe keine probleme
die teile im gepäck bei diesen 1000
transport weil wir sowieso geht man mit
den teilen um ja wenn ich stress macht
man genau das jeden fall
du weißt du schon was in einer ansonsten
dickes ding knappenweg stinken läuft ja
gesehen wie die transform wegs dingen
abgeknallt wird dann ist alles ziemlich
cool und eines ziemlich wahlspruch
rebecca horn
rüstungsexperte stecken so geil
manche verschenken
was geändert denn was wir gespannt hast
irgendwelche klasse guardians man bei
mir sind auch richtig filetieren
ich habe richtig richtig krank und
schuhe ich jetzt ganz viele aktuelle für
mich alles meins als mein vater ich
hab's eilig habe ich habe eine vermutung
musst du dir keine herzens ziehen oder
sowas und kraß es gibt glaube ich nicht
nein es wird kostet es wenn ich auf
toilette gehe ich nicht hin
warum nicht da frag ich krieg so nicht
lese und nur scheiß machst du kriegst du
gutes zeug gerade die leute ich glaube
das wird mal wieder leute ist es immer
das gleiche ich habe eine pyramide mit
ungefähr 20 lucky blöcken drin bekommen
als ob doch ich werde weiter druck sah
ich bin noch längst die alter was so
viel heißt ja ich habe ich noch viel wie
ich habe zweimal diesem bunker gefangen
es ist die absolute hölle wasser geht
what the [ __ ] das gerek direkt geld
verdiente war es also zum fix ist dass
ich weiß dass abgang game mode 0
so leute wir mussten gerade ein bisschen
manuell aufräumen hier weil es einfach
überhaupt nicht mehr klar denn in der
konsole die hexen geschrieben und mit
mit hacks lange weiß gebäude gibt es gar
nichts ja ich bin auf jeden fall
reddy gleich sekunde manche in rainbows
skeletten ich bin nicht ich bin nicht
ganz fertig viel spaß mit dem ich glaube
von mir sogar das ist kein boden durch
gegen bei den schönen sachen rum
den fand ich dachte jetzt noch einmal
dankeschön dafür finden der eine rose
getoppt gedanke was du damit alter was
für ein helm lustig oder
danke für das hin diesmal weg das jetzt
mal die er in genommen neue fragen
das display misst leute franz wird ein
problem haben
ja aber ich würde sagen franz
wir können eigentlich starten das hast
du das nicht hast party im moment jedes
coop um dich ein bisschen besser sehen
zu können
ich sehe ich sehe dich ja erst runter
geworfen
schließlich locken ok so etwas geht so
wissen junge ich hatte zehn rüstungs
bank war das mit den scheichs helm den
von ihr hatte ja seine schärfe 15
ja und ich erwarte jeder schärfe punkt
gibt 125 oder noch keine hand an sein
als ich nicht sagen
wie kannst du mich an töten hätten egal
schade hey du hast einfach nur übers
glück und also weg damit er die auch
abbauen können das kataster geräte mit
dem ding wie schnell verdammt alter das
ist halt lucky box ohne man denkt
zumindest voll okay aber der andere hat
einfach noch viel qualm lustig an dir
bekommen ja und wald bei dieser helm den
ich je hatte lucky girl i gamer helmut
oder sowas der fenster die fans deshalb
die derzeit viel mehr rüstung punkte
geben gern hätten andere behalten müssen
mich am schlagen müssen
jansch ein krasser alter hält niemals
gedacht dass das so krass ich dachte
okay wie viel angriff haben
wahrscheinlich ab die nach dem bett
gefunden hat ich würde sagen wir lassen
uns einfach wissen wie ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen